you can even see this in the stories
they don't run so the nba
the nba which i don't watch has these
two players
montrezl harrell and luca doncic i'm
i'm certain i didn't pronounce those
correctly but sort of secondary to my
point
so they were playing a basketball game
and uh
mr harrell made a good shot or something
and so as he was walking away after this
great play
you can see him mouth on camera into
close up
the phrase well bleep me if i i think
i'm allowed to say
[ __ ] ass white boy that was the phrase
that he said i don't know if i don't
know if i'm allowed to say that on the
air but if i'm not you know just believe
me
that's what he says it's like uh it's
like whap
but another but that's a variation of
that phrase
now people in the heat of sports these
are
obviously top athletes these are intense
competitors
you're going to say things you're going
to say rude things mean things get in
each other's heads
so i don't really blame this guy however
imagine if it were reversed
imagine if it weren't a black athlete
saying that to a white athlete but a
white athlete making a similar comment
to a black athlete
you would have wall-to-wall coverage 24
7 news
not only would the team be shut down the
league would be shut down maybe the
country would be shut down
with protests but
the reason that media and the liberal
establishment would encourage that
is because it would serve their ends of
sowing discord
diminishing american political unity
diminishing the ability of
the american citizens to speak to one
another to communicate to
to determine in our own deliberative
bodies how to govern ourselves
and by pushing or by ignoring this story
they move right along they continue to
stoke the flames of racial division
when it comes to blm never never any
story on the other way
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you